what we're going to do tonight Kevin and
I are going to take you on an unusual
and somewhat remarkable journey through
a remarkable place Grand Canyon but
before we do that we felt it's important
to get a little bit of an idea of how we
know each other and I think that might
reveal who we are a little bit yeah and
I should say that you know this is
probably the moment those of you who
have come here tonight expecting to get
a window into you know the sort of deep
symphonic emotional resonance that sets
up between a professional photographer
and a writer this is the moment where I
disabuse you of that delusion because
the pattern that unfolds between Pete
and I basically consists of it's
extremely simple he comes up with an
apocalyptically bad idea and in the
course of attempting to convince him of
what a bad idea this is and why we
should not do it he somehow through a
mysterious alchemy that involves
intellectual seduction manages to drag
me into the idea and I find myself and
yet another part of the world that I
didn't want to be in in the first place
all right the first bad idea was to
convince Kevin to join me in the caucus
mountains in the Republic of Georgia now
I grew up in the mountains I love skiing
and this place is where the Border
Patrol the patrols the Chechnya border
operates on skis and I was like I want
to follow these guys I want to
understand this part of the world great
idea would have been a great idea two
problems
as these guys were very very heavily
armed the second problem was that Pete
didn't check the weather report the
avalanches that resulted from the
massive series of snowstorms that
descended across the Black Sea and all
of the Republic of Georgia shut the
entire country down and we spent the
next week holed up in what should have
been a hotel except it was a bank eating
food like this all right so that wasn't
maybe that's such a good idea the next
idea had less guns higher chance of
success was to go to the north of Canada
to yukon to one of the most remote areas
up in the Arctic to follow the porcupine
caribou herd and we had this thing
dialed we're going to take the first
River North on rafts and we're going to
time it not only to see the greatest
migration of the caribou board move
across there but we're going to float
with them as they travel yeah and you'd
think that to National Geographic
journalists would be able to locate the
perky porcupine caribou herd the largest
collection of charismatic megafauna on
this on the face of North America but
know after two weeks of searching we did
not manage to locate a single live
animal
alright alright so third strike I
figured this one's going to be a home
run how could this possibly go wrong I
convinced Kevin that there's this story
on the south side of Mount Everest
that is totally unusual and it's unique
and it's not about the circus of trying
to get to the top of the mountain it's
about these guys that live let me get
that clicker to work that live inside
the Khumbu Icefall and basically build
the route for everyone else to climb the
mountain these are the unsung heroes and
they do this remarkable job of building
and engineering the route through this
Icefall that goes from 18,000 feet to
22,000 feet this is their office and
most people don't know even who they are
and here's the problem if your office
looks like this things like this tend to
happen in it a giant chunk of ice about
the size of an aircraft carrier may
break off of a cornice plummet 600 feet
onto the top of the glacier and detonate
creating a giant cloud of vaporized ice
crystals which hurtles towards you at
about a hundred miles an hour now at
this point I'm on the left side of this
photograph running for my life
and this other guy with us is doing the
same thing it's a testament to Pete's
commitment to the art of photography
that he managed to stand there and keep
shooting the reality is is I didn't know
what else to do I thought that ambulance
was going to basically snuff us out so I
figured I'd give some evidence of what
happened to us at this point however I
basically realized that maybe the
chasing these magazine stories all over
the world is maybe not maybe we need to
change maybe I'm ready to go home and it
has been a long journey and as you might
detect Kevin and I have a little bit of
a different personality I have a
tendency in part because of what I do is
to look for the light in the world I'm a
photographer I make films I'm constantly
looking for the bright side of things
I'd say I'm more optimistic and Kevin
you know he sometimes thank you a little
differently yeah that would be an
understatement
look I'm a dark person the word itself
is woven into my last name and part of
what that means is that I sort of
specialize in and my ethos as a human
being is rooted in the idea that it's
necessary and important to take the
worst possible interpretation pretty
much every situation if the sun is
shining it is raining somewhere now it's
a very sort of complex psychological
matrix that I don't fully understand the
simplest way I can explain it to you is
to put it into well let's just put it
into terms of winnie-the-pooh basically
peach is Tigger and I'm a or so at this
point Tigger and a or basically had a
small breakup I think we had a little
fatigue of going in these misadventures
together we both returned home I
returned home to Colorado this is
basically my backyard River and I
decided to do something a little
different I was getting a little tired
of chasing these short magazine stories
I wanted to do something a little longer
and sink my my heels in a little bit
more so I followed my what I call my
backyard River the Colorado River I
followed it from the mountains in the
source of Colorado basically 1,500 miles
to try to understand where does the
Western water where does this this
lifeline that supports 40 million people
in the southwest where does it go when
it travels through this desert landscape
and what happens at the end and does it
reach the end and to my amazement the
Colorado River doesn't it gets dried up
in this place right here the Sea of
Cortez 100 miles shy of the sea we dried
it up roughly two decades ago I ran to
the sea for six million years and we
turned it into basically this this
desert wasteland and what I realized at
this point is that there are a lot of
stories around rivers and water this the
arteries of our planet so to speak that
are getting untold and so I was became
very committed I think to trying to
document these stories on some level and
I made it I may have had some
notion of your commitment had I not
decided that I had temporarily stopped
speaking to Pete at this point and so I
was completely unaware that he was
engaged in this very sort of
comprehensive project that was focused
on as it turns out the very same thing
that I was focused on it's just the only
difference was it I had my eye on one
particular section of the Colorado River
I'm talking about the most storied and
legendary section of all the 277 miles
it runs through the Grand Canyon in
northern Arizona Executive River that is
defined by exceptional sections of
gorgeous light and beautiful beautiful
tranquility punctuated by moments of
unholy chaos that are known as Rapids
and it's inside of those Rapids that
some of the some of the real sort of
savagery unfolds inside the river and
the river really gives you an idea of
how powerful it truly is what it's
capable of doing to you
[Music]
that's you paddling right
that was not me paddling but there's
some truth to it because I've become
obsessed I've become obsessed with the
world of the river and I've become
obsessed with a particular story
attached to a particular man this guy's
name is Kenton gruha the legendary Grand
Canyon river guide in 1983 as Peter when
mentioned a few minutes ago he set the
speed record the standing speed record
for the fastest boat in history to race
through the Grand Canyon but ten gruha
had achieved something six years earlier
that was arguably an even greater
accomplishment it was an incredibly bold
vision the idea was what he wanted to do
was he wanted to start at the eastern
end of the Grand Canyon and walk on foot
all the way through to the western
terminus where the canyon goes through
something called the Grand wash cliffs
and ends now he was following in the
footsteps the man that Peter just
mentioned John Wesley Powell the
one-armed Civil War veteran who
accomplished one of the most
extraordinary acts in the history of
American exploration in the summer of
1869 when he led an expedition
consisting of ten men in four boats
including himself down through the
Colorado River I want you to think for a
moment about 108 years that gap between
1869 John Wesley Powell's pioneering
river voyage 1977 Kenton grew his first
traverse through the Grand Canyon and I
want you to ask yourself what that gap
says about the brokenness and brutality
and complexity of this landscape it
suggests that it is a place that does
not invite and indeed ferociously resist
human intrusion so I came back to this
broken landscape three years ago I was
invited by the National Park to do a
talk about my project on on the river
itself and I suddenly I had this kind of
Epiphany I hiked down into the canyon
and I had this idea please don't be
seduced by the rainbow
worst idea in the history of journalism
all right well that's Dior saying that
but fortunately National Geographic
agreed that this might be a good idea
actually and they agreed to sponsor us
and eventually I was able to convince
Kevin to follow in the footsteps of
Kenton gruha I'm going to be honest I'm
not sure I really like hiking that much
with a heavy pack no trail and no
guarantee of water it's hard stressful
and very slow sure
hiking can lead to some zen-like moments
but not so much if you're lost really
tired and dehydrated yet there's
something about the Grand Canyon and its
rocky secret world it is alluring
magical even so in the fall of 2015 my
friend and author kevin sadako and i set
out to walk the entirety of the Grand
Canyon from east to west in order to
understand the insanity of his venture
you first have to know a little bit
about this place some stretches it is 18
miles wide and over a mile deep so deep
in fact you could step five Empire State
buildings want to top on the other
inside it is 277 miles long if you're
floating the Colorado River but on foot
by the time you've gone up and back down
the numerous side canyons
it's more like 700 miles oh yeah
and for most of it there's no trail what
are we going I don't think we've gone
far mouse this is really hard hiking it
kind of demoralizes you a little bit as
a result more people have stood on the
surface of the Moon that have completed
a continuous through hike of the Grand
Canyon
unlike those intrepid few Kevin and I
decided to do a sectional version
chipping off 100 to 150 mile chunks at a
time just 30 hikers have completed
sectional lines through the park and for
some it took them decades to finish
tragically others have perished
attempting it Kevin and I would be the
first journalists ever to tackle this
hiking lunacy we plan to complete our
mission over a year watching the seasons
change and teaming up with hardened
Canyon veterans helped us find our way
and our legs but beyond that challenge
something else drew us on this quest
many claim the Grand Canyon is facing an
unprecedented array of pressures from
all four points from the compass
development projects are poised to
change the integrity of perhaps the most
monumental landscape in America and we
believe walking the park might give us a
unique perspective on this secret world
and what's at stake to be lost between
the river and the rim so like I said I
think I was quickly reminded how I don't
like hiking that much so the real
purpose of this project from the
beginning from the genesis of it was to
actually shine a spotlight on what's
happening in the park that as it
approaches its 100th birthday and the
reality what's happening and we're going
to walk you through some of these these
issues is getting pressure from all four
points on the compass from all sides
east west north and south and we figured
that this walk would what basically we
could walk through it the walk would be
the backbone to talk about to
we did know when we started that all
right this was maybe a place we knew the
river better than we knew the area
between the river and the rim and so we
needed some help so this guy wearing the
star-spangled banner Gators richer Udo
is one of the Guru's of the cane he
spent over 700 nights below the canyon
when we started I asked him what the
hell were these star-spangled banner
thingies there may be the most important
little item you can have if you're
drinking hanker there these Gators that
keep the ferocious angry cactus and
everything else it wants to get into
your feet ankles on of course we didn't
know what they were so we were a little
clueless on some level and but we
basically latched on to these guys he
agreed to let us follow them on their 57
day through hike they were going to
start hiking in September of 2015 and
not stop yes so this is what a is
basically what a Special Forces Grand
Canyon 18 looks like you know the level
of experience it's captured in this
photograph extends back into decades
these are men who spent an enormous
amount of time they've invested time and
energy learning this environment this is
what it looks like through their eyes
when two Yahoo's from National
Geographic show up prepared to tie
themselves onto the back of their bumper
like a couple of tin cans which raises
an interesting question why in the world
would these guys allow us to come along
the answer is interesting and it says
something about them their commitment to
the canyon and their concern over what's
happening to this environment is so
great that basically they they were they
were aware of the fact that that we were
capable of telling a story that that
they thought was incredibly important
and they were equally aware of the fact
that this environment is so difficult
physically that we will be incapable of
moving moving through it without their
assistance and so we embarked on this
journey with them starting off to the
first part of the canyon a section known
as Marble Canyon and since Kevin and I
had we've been down the river a few
times with those rode the river
successfully unsuccessfully we I however
had this idyllic view that we would do
basically a raft trip in hiking boots
you know we'd be walking and we enjoy
the tangerine light and maybe we'd have
little you know swim after six hours of
hiking Kevin might Penson poetry I might
do some time-lapse photography wrong we
quickly started realizing alright
there's a little more complex I mean we
know it's going to be hard but when you
start looking at the 23 layers of rock
inside the Grand Canyon and the endless
number of tributaries that punctured
this landscape and that you have to walk
around and leave you quickly start
realizing like this this is no raft trip
on on on foot right and that's just the
first of a whole series of problems that
start coming at you like a firehose and
all of them are routed really in one
basic fact which is that there's no
trail right and so what that means among
so many other things is that every
single step that you take in this
landscape is a careful negotiation
between you and the terrain itself it's
an act also that's complicated and made
infinitely more difficult by the heat by
your level of energy by the fact that
you are carrying on your back 50 pounds
and so when you have to perform a
dynamic and energy giant draining full
body move in order to maintain your
balance you do that over and over again
minute after minute hour after hour it's
it's so destructive to the body that by
the by the end of the first day you
basically end up looking like this
piete worst digger at this point huh
yeah I think date one day two Tigger
crawled into a dark cave with a or
pretty much wanted to just crawl into
the cave permanently at this point this
looks like a nice idyllic scene I was
expecting this you you know sit around
and tell stories under the spray of
stars at night Oh contraire this is
September late September and unusual
heatwave rolled in I just don't do well
with heat it's a hundred and ten degrees
consistently throughout the day this is
about 98 degrees we're trying to sleep
this is a furnace and this is a total
nightmare by Dave three or day four I'm
starting to feel really weird and I'm
sick I'm not thinking clearly day four
or five I've realized we are completely
in over our heads I'm not eating any
more Kevin's having a hard time with his
ankles we're in a bad spot we're in a
bad spot and most of the most of most of
it really is related to the heat it's
difficult to overstate just how
difficult it just just how awful 105
degrees is but to give you an idea I
mean one of the things it did was so hot
that the heat was literally melting the
bottoms of our shoes and and so the
story of the impact of that process had
was written in our feet for the first
couple of days but there was another
story unfolding invisibly inside of our
body that was less evident by the third
day I had descended into what seemed to
me to be a walk a bottomless well of
despair and death
and as bad as that may sound what was
happening inside of P was far more
alarming I think so
by day three I'm starting to have this
weird sensation I'm not thinking clearly
and I'm starting to get body cramps I
mean I got to a point where my tongue
cramped and my hand is like this is and
this is weird
something light right so I must be
dehydrated I wasn't peeing all day so I
start consuming a lot of water I'm
drinking salts and too but basically I
sweat a lot I sweated so much I sweated
all of my my natural sodium system out
and became hyponatremic this is the
opposite of dehydration you deplete your
salt level so low in your body that you
started to vomit water you can go
unconscious go into seizures and then a
coma I was at this point feeling like I
was headed towards unconsciousness we
realized we got to evacuate so we hiked
out we call in a friend this great guy
JP comes in brings us in salty stuff I'm
drinking soy sauce desperately and we're
able to hike out a hike that should have
taken you know three hours and normal
temperatures under normal conditions it
took us about seven hours we limp out
and crawl back to Flagstaff where I get
really the first glance of Kevin's
ankles and realize that they're totally
blown out and sprained and at this point
we're basically staring down the barrel
of failure and I'm I'm embarrassed on
one level these these amazing
thru-hikers have let us join them and
we've we've like screwed their plane up
they kept going but we delayed them a
little bit
I've brought Kevin in on this mission
where he you know he's miserably
depressed at this point and then what am
I going to tell you National Geographic
and I'm you know my friend Sadie Cory or
the editor who's here somewhere am I
going to tell her we're just total
clowns and how are we going to pull us
out because not only was I messed up I
was sick but I was frankly scared to go
back into this place it was it was
daunting it had really really beaten it
out of me yeah and I felt the same way
no surprise right
which which which which brings me to
kind of a difficult moment right now
because as it turns out we were on the
threshold of a turning point in this
journey and and and that therefore
forces me to say something positive
because much to my surprise and
unbeknownst to Pete a miracle was about
to occur and that miracle had to do with
the fact that Flagstaff is a very small
community but it sits on the edge of the
Grand Canyon and there is a very tiny
but incredibly passionate group of
people who are deeply committed to the
Grand Canyon and because it's a small
town word travels very very quickly so
we're got out that these these two
idiots from National Geographic head
head head basically tail spins out of
control retreated back to Flagstaff with
her tails between their legs and were
considering abandoning this very
important story about the Grand Canyon
and so what these people did was they
decided that they were going to rally
they showed up at my house whole group
of them and over the next two to three
weeks they redid our entire program they
redialed our gear they reengineered our
food system and they basically they
basically embarked on a process that
resulted in a Grand Canyon hiking
makeover that was designed to get us
back into the canyon back in gear and
enable us to resume the mission which
was to get our butts continuing
downstream and that we did they brought
us back in and one challenge for me is
that usually when you do these
assignments for National Geographic you
you're really afraid that if you go in
with one camera that camera breaks you
can't be like well I didn't have a
camera but it is so challenging that
they convinced me that I had to drop all
my extra lenses all my extra cameras all
my extra batteries I did the whole thing
on one camera and one lens and then they
brought us back into the canyon and
showed us ways to get through following
the sheep trails don't be near the river
follow look for the hoof prints look for
the little black pellets they brought us
through ancient ruins
brought us through two recent impacts
you can see some some old markings of
people that card their names a hundred
years ago and they basically got us back
on track to our initial mission
[Music]